>>> NEW THIS MORNING, THIS JUST
IN TO CNN, UKRAINE'S MILITARY IS
CLAIMING ONE OF ITS STRIKES
STRUCK A PLACE WHERE HUNDREDS OF
RUSSIAN TROOPS WERE BEING
HOUSED, KILLING HUNDREDS OF
THEM, THIS IN THE OCCUPIED
DONETSK REGION.
THE TROOPS WERE STATIONED NEXT
TO AN AMMUNITION CACHE, WHICH IS
SAID TO HAVE THEN EXPLODED WHEN
THE ROCKETS HIT.
UKRAINE'S MILITARY CLAIMS SOME
400 RUSSIAN SOLDIERS WERE
KILLED, 300 INJURED.
THE RUSSIANS PUT THE DEATH TOLL
AT 63.
JOINING US IS RETIRED GENERAL
JAMES "SPIDER" MARKS.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
>> HAPPY NEW YEAR.
THANK YOU.
>> FORCE PROTECTION IS THE
NUMBER ONE PRIORITY FOR TROOPS
AND THIS IS EARLY HERE.
WE DON'T KNOW ALL THE DETAILS,
BUT THE UKRAINIANS CLAIM THEY
STRUCK THE AMMUNITION CACHE AND
THAT EXPLODE AND KILLED PERHAPS
HUNDREDS OF RUSSIAN TROOPS.
SIGNIFICANCE OF THAT?
WHY WOULD TROOPS BE RIGHT NEXT
TO AN AMMUNITION DEPOT LIKE
THAT?
>> BAD DECISION TO HOUSE YOUR
TROOPS RIGHT NEXT TO WHAT'S
CALLED AN ASP, AN AMMO SUPPLY
POINT.
THE RUSSIANS HAVE INCREASINGLY
OVER THE COURSE OF THIS WAR, THE
RUSSIANS HAVE ENJOYED A CERTAIN
AMOUNT OF SANCTUARY.
I'M NOT CERTAIN WHERE THE AMMO
SUPPLY POINT WAS SPECIFICALLY,
BUT WHAT UKRAINE HAS BEEN ABLE
TO DO EFFECTIVELY IS ENGAGE
RUSSIAN FORCES ONE-ON-ONE IN
TACTICAL FIGHTS.
WHAT HAS BEEN INCREASING IN
THEIR CAPABILITY IS THEIR
ABILITY TO CONDUCT LONG-RANGE
FIRES AND TO SYNCHRONIZE THAT
WITH ACTIVITIES ON THE GROUND.
THAT'S CREATING THIS BUBBLE OF
SYNCHRONIZATION, THIS AIR/LAND
BATTLE SPACE AND ACHIEVE EFFECTS
ON THE GROUND.
WHEN YOU ACHIEVE SANCTUARY, AND
THE RUSSIANS IN MANY CASE THINK
THEY HAVE SANCTUARY BEHIND ENEMY
LINES, YOU PUT YOURSELF AT GREAT
RISK AND YOU MAKE A LOT OF
STUPID DECISIONS LIKE THIS.
>> PERHAPS AN EFFECT OF THE
HIMARS, ONE OF THE MISSILE
SYSTEMS THAT HAS HAD AN IMPACT
IN THE BATTLE THERE.
I WANT TO ASK ABOUT THE OTHER
SIDE, LOSSES ON THE OTHER SIDE,
THAT'S THESE CONTINUING RUSSIAN
MISSILE AND DRONE STRIKES ON
UKRAINIAN CITIES.
A LOT OF THEM GET SHOT DOWN, A
LOT OF THEM DON'T.
THE U.S. IS SENDING ONE PATRIOT
BATTERY TO BOLSTER UKRAINIAN AIR
DEFENSES.
IS THAT INSUFFICIENT?
IF SO, WHY NOT MORE?
>> VERY INSUFFICIENT.
LOOK, WHERE THIS PATRIOT BATTERY
IS GOING TO BE DEPLOYED WILL
PROVIDE TREMENDOUS POINT-AIR
DEFENSE, IN OTHER WORDS, THE
AREA AROUND WHERE THAT BATTERY
IS DEPLOYED, PROBABLY SIX
LAUNCHERS WILL ENJOY AN
INCREASED AMOUNT OF PROTECTION.
THE PATRIOT IS QUITE A
PHENOMENAL CAPABILITY.
IN ORDER TO PROTECT
INFRASTRUCTURE, SCHOOLS,
HOSPITALS, ALL THE TARGETS --
ALL THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT THE
RUSSIANS ARE GOING AFTER, YOU
NEED A MUCH LARGER ARRAY OF AIR
DEFENSE CAPABILITIES.
RIGHT NOW THE UKRAINIANS HAVE A
MIX OF FORMER SOVIET-RUSSIAN
CAPABILITIES, NOW THIS PATRIOT
BATTERY WILL BE COMING INTO THE
FIGHT, BUT PROBABLY NOT FOR A
COUPLE OF MONTHS BECAUSE THE
TRAIN-UP PERIOD FOR THAT IS
SIGNIFICANT.
THIS IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION BUT IT'S INSUFFICIENT.
>> AND IT'S THE BIGGEST COUNTRY
IN EUROPE, IT'S A LOT OF
TERRITORY TO DEFEND.
WE HAVE HEARD UKRAINIAN
OFFICIALS WARNING ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL FOR A BIG RUSSIAN
OFFENSIVE IN THE NEW YEAR.
SOME I HAVE SPOKE TO SAID THEY
DON'T HAVE THE CAPABILITY TO DO
SO.
WHAT DO YOU EXPECT?
>> THEY DON'T.
THE RUSSIANS HAVE A CERTAIN
LEVEL OF SELF-AWARENESS, THEY'VE
BEEN GETTING THEIR BUTTS KICKED,
THEY REALIZE THAT.
WHEN THEY ENGAGE WITH
UKRAINIANS, THEY HAVE ZERO
RESULT.
I THINK WHAT RUSSIA WOULD LIKE
TO DO IS HAVE BELA-RUSSIANS ORS
COME DOWN DIRECTLY TO KYIV AND
MOVE FORCES UP TO THE DONBAS AND
TRY TO CONNECT THESE TWO AND TRY
SOME SYNCHRONIZATION, BUT THEY
LACK THE ABILITY.
THE RUSSIAN MILITARY HAS
ESTABLISHED IT'S INCOMPETENT,
LEADERLESS, THE LEADERS THEY DO
HAVE ARE IMMORAL AND CRIMINALS,
SO THEY DON'T HAVE THE
CAPABILITY TO DO THAT.
BUT THERE IS THE LAW OF LARGE
NUMBERS.
THEY HAVE THE CAPABILITY TO
CONDUCT THESE ARTILLERY ATTACKS
AND THESE DRONE ATTACKS.
I DON'T SEE A LARGE MANEUVER
OPERATION ON THE PART OF THE
RUSSIANS.
>> PUNISHING THE CIVILIAN
POPULATION WHERE THEY CAN'T GAIN
ON THE GROUND.
MAJOR GENERAL "SPIDER" MARKS,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
TURNING NOW TO RUSSIA'S WAR ON
UKRAINE.
FOR THE THIRD STRAIGHT DAY,
ATTACKS TARGETING CIVILIAN AND
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE.
AUTHORITIES ARE URGING
RESIDENTS TO REDUCE THEIR
ENERGY USE AMID EMERGENCY POWER
CUTS.
THE UKRAINIAN MILITARY SAYS IT
SHUT DOWN DOZENS OF IRANIAN
MADE DRONES OVERNIGHT.
IT COMES DAYS AFTER RUSSIA
LAUNCHED A BLISTERING WAVE OF
DEADLY MISSILE AND DRONE
ATTACKS ON NEW YEAR'S EVE, IN
WHAT HEAT IS CALLING AN
INTIMIDATION TACTIC.
CNN'S BEN WEDEMAN JOINS US LIVE
FROM THE UKRAINIAN CAPITAL.
THEN, A SUGGESTION FROM KYIV
THAT THIS IS AS MUCH ABOUT THE
FACT THAT THEY ARE NOT WINNING
ON THE GROUND AS THE ATTACKS IN
THE SKY.
>> THAT'S REALLY BEEN THE CASE,
GOING BACK TO SEPTEMBER, WHEN
THE RUSSIANS SUFFERED THAT
DEFEAT IN THE KHARKIV REGION.
THE RUSSIANS HAVE BEEN
INCREASINGLY TARGETED THE
INFRASTRUCTURE, PARTICULARLY
THE ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE OF
THIS COUNTRY.
AS FAR AS KYIV GOES, MAX, OVER
FOUR OF THE LAST FIVE DAYS, WE
HAVE SEEN STRIKES ON THE
CAPITOL HERE.
FOR THE WEEKEND, AS MANY AS 45.
THEY ARE USING THESE SHAHED
1:35 IRANIAN MADE DRONES, WHICH
EXPLODE UPON IMPACT.
THE STRIKE ON NEW YEAR'S EVE,
IT KILLED ONE PERSON AT THE,
TIME DOZENS OF OTHERS WERE
INJURED.
BUT ANOTHER PERSON OF THOSE
INJURED HAS PASSED AWAY TODAY.
AS YOU MENTIONED, THE
AUTHORITIES HERE CALLING UPON
PEOPLE TO CONSERVE THEIR USE OF
ELECTRICITY BECAUSE OF THE
DAMAGE CAUSED TO THE POWER
SYSTEM.
NOW, WE ARE ALSO HEARING FROM
THE RUSSIAN NEWS AGENCY THAT AS
MANY AS 63 RUSSIAN SOLDIERS
WERE KILLED ON A STRIKE,
UKRAINIAN STRIKE, ON MAKIIVKA.
WHICH IS IN THE OCCUPIED PART
OF THE DONETSK REGION.
UKRAINIANS CONTINUE TO FIGHT
BACK, CLEARLY, SOMEONE
EFFECTIVELY.
MAX?
>> IN TERMS OF WHAT KYIV IS
PREPARING FOR NOW, HOW ARE THEY
DEALING WITH THEIR STRATEGY
THROUGH THE WINTER?
HOW CAN THEY COPE WITH THESE ON
SLOTS?
>> IT DEPENDS UPON HOW BADLY
THE INFRASTRUCTURE IS HIT ON
ANY GIVEN DAY.
THEY'RE ABLE TO REPAIR AND TO A
CERTAIN EXTENT, BUT GIVEN THAT
THIS IS BECOMING AN ALMOST
DAILY OCCURRENCE, IT'S GOING TO
BE HARDER AND HARDER TO KEEP
THAT SYSTEM RUNNING.
NOW, VARIOUS COUNTRIES HAVE
PROVIDED EMERGENCY GENERATORS.
BUT THAT MAY NOT BE ENOUGH.
AFTER ALL, KYIV IS A CITY OF
SEVERAL MILLION PEOPLE.
YOU CAN ONLY BRING IN SO MANY
GENERATORS AND FUEL TO POWER
THEM.
SO, THEY ARE DOING THE BEST
THEY CAN UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
BUT IF THIS RUSSIAN ONSLAUGHT
CONTINUES, AT SOME POINT, IT
MAY SIMPLY OVERWHELM THE
AUTHORITIES ABILITY TO KEEP THE
SYSTEM GOING.
MAX?
>> BEN WEDEMAN, THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US FROM KYIV.